this morning we're remembering emmett
till
on the 65th anniversary of his killing
the 14 year old black teenager was
brutally murdered by
two white men after he was accused of
whistling at a white woman in
mississippi
till's death stirred nationwide outrage
and became a catalyst in the civil
rights movement
a cbsn special airing tonight the power
of august
shows us how till's killing in 1955
and the death of george floyd this year
triggered movements
for change let's go back to vladimir
duche vlad good morning again
anthony as you noted it's been decades
since emmett till was killed
but the painful legacy of his death
still seems fresh amid the civil unrest
we've been seeing
worldwide surrounding the murder of
george floyd i want to warn some of you
the images you're about to see may be
disturbing
life for most black men and women in
1950s america
was a daily struggle their lives were
separate and unequal and especially in
the south
black people knew their lives were also
at risk
there was overt racism it was
open and notorious and for a young man
like emmett till to travel from chicago
to the mississippi delta it was a world
of difference
that difference would be a matter of
life and death for 14 year old emmett
till
in august 1955 his mother sent him to
mississippi
to spend the summer with his relatives
his family loved young emmett's jovial
personality
but as his cousin wheeler parker jr told
60 minutes ed bradley back in 2004
it wasn't something the flaunt in the
segregated south he was a center of
attraction he loved pranks he loved fun
he's kind of a natural born leader
why would that be a problem in
mississippi why would it be a problem
it would be a problem because the
mississippians
what he thought was just fun or a joke
wasn't funny to them
which is why no one laughed when young
emmett whistled at a white woman
a joke that would cost him his life
emmett's late mother mamie till would
describe
what was left of her only child i was
looking
at his ears and that's when i discovered
a hole about here
and i could see daylight on the other
side
i said i want the world to see this
because when people saw what had
happened
to this little 14 year old boy
they knew then that not only
were black men in danger
but black children as well there were
ten thousand people
who saw that body in chicago many
millions more who saw it because of the
photograph
in jet magazine in may
2020 tens of millions more saw the video
of 46 year old george floyd take his
last breath
i think that snapshot of the officer
kneeling on his neck
the cry that we heard from george floyd
for his mother
mama it really was incredibly powerful
[Applause]
today also marks the 57th anniversary of
the march on washington that is of
course where the reverend martin luther
king jr gave
his famous i have a dream speech in 1963
tens of thousands are expected to gather
at the lincoln memorial to commemorate
the historic march what did some of the
civil rights leaders say to you
about the protest and the activism that
we're seeing in the streets today i'll
bet it brings back a lot of memories for
them too
uh you're exactly right gail in fact uh
both young and old
those leaders told us there's a direct
lineage between what we saw
in the 50s and 60s to what we're seeing
today the one difference
is that we are seeing this movement
worldwide you're seeing people holding
up black lives matter signs
in denmark in france all over the world
that kind of allyship
is really sort of unique to where we are
in this moment
at this time it's still jarring though
to see the body the picture of emmett
till and
god bless his mother for sharing that
picture it definitely changed the game
and made a huge
impact thank you very much vlad